The process we just went
through will repeat.
But running Saga a second time will
create totally new execution context
instead of referencing
the original blue context.
This accommodates for
storage of different bindings.
As ever, the interpreter's
lookup focus will also shift
into the newly created content.
The var declaration creates
a new variable in this context.
And if you like to think about the
storage layout that languages use for
your data, you could say that
this variable is stored in
a new distinct location
from the first one.
Now while this isn't necessarily
the case, it's likely true and
it's a useful way to think about it.
What values do you expect
to be logged by this line,
given the current in memory conditions